wir wollen weitermachen und ins
wohnzimmer deutschlands blicken und
schalten jetzt da sehen wir sie schon so
willi herren und jasmin herren und zwar
nach einer kurzen trennung sind sie
wieder glücklich vereint ihr habt euch
jetzt selber in quarantäne begeben
freiwillig sozusagen ich wollte mal
fragen wie geht es euch denn jetzt also
uns geht es soweit ganz gut und zelte
ein bisschen die decke aus dem kopf
manchmal ist und ein bisschen langweilig
aber wir sind der kreative köpfe also
ich finde die zeit wirklich wunderbar
ich genieße das ich bin ja sonst sehr
wenig zu hause so viel zeit aber in den
letzten jahren gar nicht miteinander
verbracht und es schweißt uns zusammen
wir nutzen die zahlen hier werden
kreative gehen jeden tag fast jeder live
auf unserem instagram account und machen
immer diesen sogenannten herrentag da
kann man uns fragen was man will
wir wollen unsere community näher
kennenlernen das funktioniert auch alles
wunderbar teilweise sind wir bis zu vier
stunden on und i'll be rich kommt klar
mit der situation und ich bin viel zeit
für meine frau ungelernt und wir lernen
uns immer wieder neu kennt und das ist
das schön und sein wann habt ihr denn
jetzt schon aufeinander
also jetzt 16
heute ja die sind heute aber kurz raus
die waren zu gast das erste mal waren
wir wir waren zu gast bei marco schreyl
in der sendung geben und da muss man
sagen die haben auf sicherheit geachtet
der abstand wurde eingehalten alles
wurde ein bisschen verzieren die wurden
auch nicht geschminkt wir haben und
dieses so genannte deutschland habe mir
selber gemacht sind ein studio aber es
war ein ganz komische situation
also das war unser erster ausgang heute
dann aber die pizza geholt und die aber
im gesetz nun jetzt mal mit ihr sina und
für das ganze interessant das thema weil
unser liebesleben schleppen
wir sehen ganz zufrieden und 16 tage
ich glaube ich habe schon ein paar kilo
da einfach sehr schön zu wissen auf
jeden fall ich wollte einfach wissen wie
schafft ihr es auch freiraum zu halten
quasi das nicht
lasst euch nicht zu sehr vielleicht
nerven könntet ihr nervt mich nicht sina
da sagte jetzt sagt jetzt klein also
momentan gegen uns wirklich nicht und
sagt wir haben ja auch wirklich auf und
ab war ja fast drei monate auseinander
in der zeit gemerkt sie hat sich eine
wohnung gesucht ich habe mich irgendwie
in der wohnung gesucht und haben dann in
der zeit gemerkt als komplettes altes
haus das ganze inventar verkauft haben
aber dann gemerkt wir sind immer mehr
und mehr zusammen gerückt obwohl sie
eine wohnung gesucht ein echter baum
wohnung gesucht habe ja irgendwann war
dann keinen fernseher mehr da kein bett
mehr da und alles verkauft haben wir
ganz doll angefangen wir sind jetzt in
der neuen wohnung und fühlen uns
wunderbar und irgendwann saßen wir dann
zusammen nach bei monaten haben oder wir
können ja nicht ohne einander
und da man sonst schnell gemerkt dass
wir einfach zusammengehören und viele
äußere einflüsse dazu beigetragen dass
wir diesen weg gegangen sind aber jeder
größe sind wir sind ein glückliches paar
und auch in böse zungen behaupten das
wäre mehr gewesen
die spinnen doch weil wir so was
manchmal keine pr ist so viel
medienpräsenz und da brauche ich nicht
in der schlagzeile mich aus und dieser
heißt wie rente steigen an mir das ist
halt bei uns sowie sind zwei alphatiere
die aufeinander getroffen sind und da
wenn wir uns setzen dann setzte uns auch
richtig aber wir haben jetzt halt
gemerkt wie gehören jetzt zu sagen wir
sind wahr obwohl ja jeder eine wohnung
gesucht hat in eine gemeinsame wohnung
gezogen und wir sind sehr glücklich und
tut die zeit wirklich gut sie mal
wir rücken noch mehr zusammen kochen wir
renovieren die wohnung bekommen auf ganz
bescheiden und wenn ich sage ich mir
erzählt meine gerade mit seiner
bauchrednerpuppe die habe ich schon
lachen geschenkt hätten also ich kann
das ein bisschen ich will das jetzt sich
vormachen
ich bin gerade dabei ich habe da könnt
ihr die zeit
sehr schön und so große leidenschaft von
mir ich liebe bauchredner und cooper
mittlerweile tutorials an und das ist
die bauchrednerpuppe wir haben noch
kleiner und essen aber das böse es nicht
gibt ja auch nicht mehr
ja ist er sie sieht doch nur gut aus und
aber ich kann über verwundere es kann
auch mal was du jetzt schon gelernt
haben in quarantäne
wir arbeiten noch daran habe ich ganz
neu und ich glaube gerade dieser tage
viele tattoos an und ich übe jedoch im
geheimen
ich glaube ich dass dort nichts zu
präsentieren wenn es dann nicht klappt
ausgesagt werde so ausgereift ist dann
möchte ich auch meinen neuen freund tor
letzte frage an euch habt ihr tipps für
andere party jetzt sehr viel zeit
zusammen verbringen ruhig näher zusammen
und redeten wir haben an die tagesthemen
heute journal und natürliche bild
zeitung jedoch und alles was es über
koch instituts von sich gibt
ansonsten also neben twist glücklich es
gibt eine tolle app die heißt hausparty
kann man sich runterladen ist kostenfrei
ist keine werbung die ich hier machen
wir dieses für diese app kommt nix da
kann man nicht von 16 personen
gleichzeitig reinlegen kommunizieren
spielen also ich kann immer kriegszeit
auch wie gesagt wir rücken noch näher
zusammen und wir gehen uns noch nicht
gesagt obwohl manchmal schon aber auch
da ich kaufe sehr schön an vielen dank
euch beiden hat sehr viel spaß gemacht
und bleibt so gut gelaunt und vor allem
gesund zurück alles gute und dankeschön